Hey, this is interesting.
Um, I've talked before about a tool called
the d feasibility tests
that can be a useful tool when we're talking
about politics.
And I first heard about it, uh, I believe
from Peter Bogosian and then I learned about
some other versions of it from others.
And the idea is to interject and sort of slow
down a conversation that might be going nowhere
or where you're not likely to make any progress
by asking what evidence would make you change
your position.
So if we were debating abortion, for example,
I might say to someone who is an anti choicer
against abortion, what evidence, if I could
present it to you, would get you to change
your mind about this issue.
And they might say, well, if you could prove
a, you know, a fetus isn't a person or they
might say, if I learned God didn't exist,
then I might change my mind about abortion.
It's not so much about what the answer is
specifically, but about getting them to think
like is there actually something that would
change your mind or are you irrationally tied
to this idea?
Are you tied to this idea?
Not because of anything factual, so evidence
doesn't even really matter.
That's the sort of gist of the defensibility
test and CNN host John Berman ran the defensibility
tests on former Trump communications director
Anthony Scaramucci and Scaramucci completely
imploded in the sense that he rambled for
minute after minute after minute not answering
the question.
The question was what could Trump do to make
you Anthony Scaramucci stop supporting him
and look at how long, like I'm not even going
to play it all because it goes on so long.
Look at how long Scaramucci just rambles on
without actually answering the question here.
As we sit here this morning, do you still
support president Trump?
Yeah, of course.
I support each Ya.
I'm a very John, I'm a very loyal guy.
I remember I got fired two years ago.
Loyalty.
Loyalty is one thing.
But then the question is, Anthony, then if
the answer is yes, I own, who's still still
where the president this morning, what would
it take?
What would it take for you?
I do to stop supporting the president.
I, well, I, I think he's going in a direction,
and I said this a couple of weeks ago on your
air is going in a direction where there's
a very large group of people that actually
want to support him or actually begging him
to give us reasons to support you.
A, he's going in a direction where I guess
he doesn't want that support or he wants people
to have this twisted like a pretzel loyalty
tests with him where he's going to do things
that are not making any sense.
But I want you to go out there and sorta defend
it.
Okay.
And so I, I think there's a large group of
people that are going to stop doing that.
And then eventually people will say, look,
I'm sorry, the value system and the rhetoric
does not outweigh the policies.
Okay.
And so at some point that will happen and
has not happened for me yet, but there's a
lot of us out here.
It's not, it's not just me.
I'm a little bit more vocal, perhaps a tinge
more courageous to admit it, but trust me,
it's former White House administration officials.
It's former cabinet members.
It's former people in the American military.
It's not, it's not just me.
It's not like I'm the only one.
I may be the only one saying it, but trust
me, there's a very large group of people.
If he keeps it up, they'll say, okay, the
policies, they're great, but you know why?
This sort of rhetoric and this sort of disunity
sort of stuff is over powering the policy,
so Scaramucci has no answer.
He just repeated that confusing thing over
and over again and he's reduced to sort of
a blubbering and stuttering mess.
Really nicely done by John Berman.
Not that it's that complex of a technique.
You just say, Oh, what would get you to change
your mind about that?
Now it's common that in many situations, if
you asked this to someone, what evidence,
if I could present it to you, would it would
change your mind?
Very often people don't immediately have an
answer, but sometimes again, the point is
not to have an answer, but to get the person
thinking about whether they are blindly or
irrationally attached to a position for lots
of these Trumpists.
The answer actually is to this question.
Nothing.
Nothing would get them to reconsider their
support.
For Donald Trump, I had a funny color.
Must've been maybe like a year ago, might've
even been a year and a half ago on the show.
Big Trump is who started by saying to me on
the phone, if Trump doesn't build the wall
during his first term, he doesn't have my
support in 2020 and within about a minute.
I said much more concretely.
So you said if Trump does not build the wall
before 2020 you don't vote for him in 2020
is that right?
And the Trump has on the phone immediately
started hedging and saying, well, I mean it
depends on why he doesn't build it.
If he doesn't build it because Democrats get
in the way, then that's different.
It sorta depends and then we very quickly
figured out actually there really wasn't anything
that would stop him from voting for Trump
in 2020 because any failure of Trump or apparent
failure of Trump, he was going to after the
fact that tribute a blame for to someone else.
In the case of the wall it was going to be
Democrats.
So this is a really good question for exposing
dogmatic ideologues and then another one that
can be productive.
This one, my friend Jay Tomlinson hosted the
best of the left podcast told me about this
one.
Why do you think I hold this position on a
particular issue?
So it's much harder for people to say your
position is basically because you're a moron
that you've come to this conclusion or you're
a bad person.
When you're starting to have a conversation
about an issue, you actually say to someone,
okay, let's talk about healthcare.
You know my position before we start talking
about it.
Why do you think I have the position I have
about healthcare?
And it is much more difficult for people to
attribute bad faith when you actually say
to them, tell me how you think I arrived at
my conclusion.
Uh, if you've had success with either or both
of these techniques, let me know, maybe during
live calls later on this week.
Uh, I would love to hear from, from folks
who have actually tried out some of these
tactics.